if this is not a basic habit for you I
need you to start scoring yourself at
the end of the day people really don't
like this one and I'm just going to be
upfront about that you probably won't
want to do this and a lot of people
don't but if there's something inside of
you that is restless for that next level
we're going to have to start measuring
if you don't measure it you can't
improve it you know if you ever try to
lose weight or gain you've noticed
apparently this is weightlifting talk
but if you've ever tried to like get
stronger you got to write it down like
how many reps did you do what routines
did you do today how much weight did you
use like if you do that in the gym well
you got to do that in the playground of
life too but most don't and they're
really struggling I can't tell you it's
it's like painful to watch I'll show up
and I'll like tell me about your life
and first they don't even know where to
start because they never measure
themselves
and then second in the dialogue with me
as a high performance coach I find them
disappointed upset
struggling unsure themselves and a lot
of that could be handled if on a more
consistent basis they were self-aware
and personally accountable to their own
behavior and growth it isn't it true
don't you know somebody with oh my gosh
I wish that person would like stop at
the end of the day and say am I being a
good person isn't there someone you're
so frustrated with right now in life who
you just love to sit down and say hey
you need to be more self-aware you you
aren't being paying attention to who
you're being and it's hurting everybody
around you jerk you know we all have
that person we wish they were more
self-aware hey it's Evan Carl Michael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the source for myself today too so
today let's learn from some of the best
and pick up some of the most powerful
habits to start your day with
enjoy
how do you get self-awareness you just
go to a meditative Retreat once a year
do you look out into being a self-aware
person
self-awareness is gained by
self-evaluation
if you want to agree better aware of who
you are
where you can grow how you can uniquely
give or serve we need to evaluate
yourself does this make sense so what
are your habits right now for evaluating
yourself
what do they look like
how are you measuring yourself and your
progress in life
what are those
if you got some man virtual high five I
could be there with you you know
celebrate that that's awesome right
that's incredible because most people
don't do that so I hope that you are
doing that but it's a struggle for a lot
of people too so here's a simple way
that you can end your day scoring
yourself along the lines of again what
we're talking about your productivity
specifically you might have other ways
you might score your personal values you
might score your energy you might score
how much influence you had with other
people I'm going to give you some
related to what we talked about
productivity so we can get some quick
wins and gains for you as we jump into
more in-depth training here's what those
are I would like ask yours have yourself
ask yourself at the end of the day
these specific statements and then rate
yourself low one means you suck okay
five means you're awesome you're doing a
good job okay so let's walk through
these number one I worked on things that
mattered most today I know that's basic
so I'll go fast here number two I
progressed a major dream or goal today
meaning did you progress today number
three I avoided the distractions well
today number four I set intentions
before each major activity today that's
a huge one number five I fully engage
and enjoyed my efforts today because
High performers strives satisfied
they're engaged and in that engagement
they find joy and they find fulfillment
satisfaction confidence it's by engaging
so how did you do today did you enjoy
your efforts or not now remember low one
one one one high five where are you here
so every day I sit myself down and I
started scoring myself this is probably
about seven years ago and remember you
know seven years ago I was still then a
certified high performance coach seven
years ago I was like my career was just
taking off and what we want to believe
is that people just kind of bumble into
progress people Bumble into momentum I'm
telling you high performers are more
strategic and they're more
self-evaluative now many of them this
was a
unconscious competence for them they
really didn't know that their self-talk
was so oriented towards self-evaluation
until I did some coaching and
interviewing with them to discern that
but it turns out High performers they're
measuring stuff now I just want to make
it easier for you so here's a simple
tool just write those things down
then score yourself now when you score
yourself at the end of the day add your
score up so let's say you're threes all
the way down the 3 6 9 12 15.
Montana kid doing math and it was right
okay one two three four five so let's
say you're 15. so yeah I just go up
that'd be 15. then multiply it by 4 15
times 4 is 60. that will give you a
score of 100 percent okay whatever your
score is keep seeking Clarity each day
and you'll get better and better and
better try to improve this each day look
there's going to be days your two other
days are five but the goal is to ask
yourself this like I want you to do
something and if this sounds too basic
here's what I want you to do and add to
your routine that maybe you already have
maybe you end your day with journaling
congratulations not enough okay instead
what I want you to do is create your own
scoring mechanism for the end of the day
whether it's taking a page out of my
playbook here or you're scoring yourself
right if I ask you how'd you do today
and you go good
that's one level of self-evaluation but
if I say how did you do today and I give
you a specific context how did I how did
you do today in keeping to your own
agenda
that you might say ah good or pretty
well but if I say how did you do today
in keeping to your own agenda on a scale
of one to ten one you sucked and got
pulled into everybody else's agenda you
got totally distracted you didn't get
anything done you wanted to ten you were
superbly excellent today
you stayed on point
it's different quality isn't it when you
got to rate yourself and you're like I
was a six and then my next question he
goes well why you were why were you a
six versus say a 10.
then you can go oh well because
I made these decisions
or I allowed that
or this person did this
okay great okay well what would it take
to go from a six to a ten
well I would have had to have done this
or next time I would do this right as
soon as you score yourself you have an
anchor or a benchmark from which to move
yourself and a different level of
self-evaluation so what could you I know
I'm talking along about this there's one
reason I'm trying to get you in your own
unconscious mind right now to be
generating a lot of ways you could score
yourself because for me there's 50
different things I score myself on at
the end of the day 50. now now here's
the thing I don't let my low numbers bum
me out
because the truth is you know what uh
measuring myself across 50 things every
day it's not like I'm a robot I'm like
you know it's not like
um I'm perfect in every one of those
areas
but here's what happens
let me tell you this this is a huge
Insight so please write this down
if you're not scoring yourself
consistently
that's why you feel so out of balance
if you're not scoring yourself
consistently that's why you feel
yourself so out of balance it's why you
know one day you realize you've been
working so hard but you neglected the
kids why did you neglect the kids
because you're a bad person or a bad
parent no it's because you didn't have
the quality of your experience with them
on a radar on a dashboard on a sheet at
the end of each day or maybe each week
and so what happens is you know life
takes hold of us that we get kind of the
stream of life and we're just kind of
getting carried along and then one day
we wake up and we realize wait I'm like
seven I'm like seven I've done seven
different you know River channels that I
didn't anticipate right and so the only
way to keep us there
is to evaluate and I think if you can do
that things significantly shift so I
hope that you'll figure out what is your
end of day scoring I'm sure well I've
been talking even thinking of other
things you could score your energy
you could score how you treated your
wife or your kids or your team you could
score how much you stayed focused you
could score how well you actually made
sales or how well you dealt with clients
or how well you built your business I
don't know what it is for you but if you
don't know what it is for you and if you
aren't scoring I know the next level is
right there for you it's right there so
put this in play habit number two is
reverse self-doubt with Mel Robbins
self-doubt is a habit
it's a behavior a thinking pattern that
you repeat over and over and then it
becomes automated
and when I can get you to understand
that anxiety
worry
procrastination self-doubt they are all
habits
that I can show you using science how
you can break them and then everything
changes and it all comes back to these
five second decisions if you had more
confidence how would your business and
life change for the better
I'm going to tell you how mine had when
I finally learned
what confidence is and what it isn't
number one I know how to say no
how many of you have a hard time saying
no you have clients you can't stand you
have people that work for you that drain
you
uh the ability to align your goals with
values and actions Fearless negotiator
Fearless
greater self-control by the way let me
stop there for a second because I
believe that in today's world this is
the number one skill for you
self-control and we're going to give you
tools today that are gave it to you
you're gonna make a lot more money and
you're going to be a happier human being
absolutely and I'm going to show you how
to do it we can talk about change all
you want
but I'm the kind of person that's about
real advice for real people and that's
going to require some real action
so as I'm talking I want you to notice
what are the physical Sensations the
feelings that come up in your body
when I ask you how would your life
change if you had more confidence and
you have an answer do you feel yourself
shrinking
do you feel yourself Talking yourself
out or raising your hand
because if I can get you to start to
isolate that pattern and that habit
simply in how you respond to whether or
not you're going to answer this question
if I can break that right there so that
you learn to try
I almost fell off I'm gonna oh God
there's a thing you learn to try thank
you but it's like cert crowd surf right
now you got me okay
then you can bring that anywhere
I'm into experiential learning because
you know I got dyslexia I'm add it's
really hard for me to read and retain so
if I feel it if I have to do it then it
sticks so let's talk about the myths and
the truths about confidence okay number
one confidence is a personality trait
total baloney
total baloney
lots of extroverted people that are
really bossy and annoying like I used to
be although I might still be a little
annoying
um but really insecure
really insecure there's a lot of
introverted folks that feel
uncomfortable putting themselves out
there but they're they really believe in
what they're saying
so confidence is not a personality trait
confidence is fixed that's not true you
could be the most confident person in
the world and the person that you love
leaves you
that's going to rock confidence
you could be a really great business
person and then make a really bad
decision
and blow it all
that's going to rock you
number three the confidence starts with
belief
this is where I go against so many other
people
I actually believe that this is not true
I think that
thinking positive thoughts
will certainly make you feel better in
the moment
but it's not going to create change that
you want that you can be a negative
frustrated depressed anxiety-ridden son
of a gun
and you can still take action
and that taking action is key you see
here's the truth about confidence first
of all it's not a skill it's a trait
and that's good news I mean excuse me
it's not a trait oh it's a skill it's
not a trait see dyslexia on full display
I was not lying about that confidence is
a skill it's not a trait
confidence is situational
so there are areas of your life where
you are confident and then there are
areas of your life where you have a ton
of doubt and here's the most important
one confidence begins with action now
this is not something that I made up and
in a second I'm going to show you the
science I want you to write this quote
down
if you have a problem
that can be solved with action
you don't have a problem
so a lot of us talk about the problems
that we have but they're actually not
problems
we're stuck in one of the traps of
self-doubt
and that's what we're going to be
talking about in just a second but first
I want to show you how you build
confidence and let's let's look at the
research
because there's really really strong
research on this if you want more
information on this just Google the
confidence competency Loop
the confidence competency Loop let me
show you what this is
so basically if you try something
he's either going to succeed or he's
going to survive now what happens if you
survive it like you really blow it but
you survive it
well you learned something
and then when you learn something what
are you doing you're building skills and
when you're building skills at something
what are you gaining competency
all competency means is that by learning
something over and over and over again
you have to do less thinking about it so
you don't have time to get anxious just
like me in the bed I had time to lay
there so I was thinking about all my
problems the more you do something the
more that you try the more you build
skill and competency and that is where
confidence comes
so I want you to walk out of here not
only with the 54321
catch yourself when you feel yourself
shrinking catch yourself when you feel
yourself editing yourself or silencing
yourself
I also want you to walk out of here with
a brand new definition of confidence
which I'm going to give to you in a
second because check this out all of us
are going to feel failure
let me show you what happens when you
are afraid of failing when you're when
you're fearing it first of all you're
going to start thinking aren't you oh I
don't know if I want to give a speech I
might be really bad at it and then I
don't know what I want to talk about and
I'm not really sure am I ready am I not
ready should I wear the tennis shoes
should I wear the heels should I not go
this should I do this and then of course
as you think you're going to start to
doubt yourself
and this becomes this Loop this is what
um researchers call a habit loop we're
going to get more into this this is a
chunk of behavior that gets encoded in
this part of your brain you see you
don't you're not a doubter you have a
habit of doing it the same is true by
the way when you feel nervous
you start overthinking the same is true
when you start feeling insecure the same
is true when you feel like a fake the
same is true when you start to get
overwhelmed the same is true when you
start to fear rejection all of those
things normal it's normal to be afraid
of being rejected it sucks
it's normal to feel nervous these
feelings are
normal
acting nervous is a choice
there's only one way to break a habit
Loop you have to insert a different
Behavior
pretty neat huh
see we spend way too much time with the
red arrows
I gotta be Fearless
I can't never I can't ever worry
I I you know it's terrible to feel like
a fake no it's not it's normal
in fact you're going to
when you first relaunch your Eco
Adventure company you're going to feel
like a fake
that is normal acting like one
is a choice
so the only way to break the habit of
self-doubt and thinking is to take
action and what action are you going to
take five four three two one
and that if you do it over and over puts
a new habit in place
this is how you build confidence one
five second decision at a time let me
show you a little bit more science so
right here is your your brain
and the red part right there that's the
basal ganglia that's where all your
habit Loops get encoded everything that
you do that you don't think about
worrying
let me give you another example
um when you put on your pants do you put
your right or your left leg in first
you're thinking about it aren't you
you don't when you pull your jeans on
it's a pattern of behavior that is right
here here's the other problem this is
also where worry is this is where
anxiety is this is where depression is
this is where self-doubt is it's all
right here this is where procrastination
is what happens when you go five four
three two one
is you activate the prefrontal cortex
which you know is the part of the brain
that you need for strategic thinking for
acting with courage for changing so the
truth is in five seconds you can change
anything and that changes everything
I want you to understand that to feel
more confident about the things that you
want to do in your next chapter it
begins with being willing to try
so if confidence is the decision to try
because I also like the idea of you not
thinking that the big topics like
confidence are about how you feel
I want to make them action based because
you can't control how you feel at times
but you can always choose how you act so
if confidence is the decision to try
here's the definition of self-doubt
it's the decision not to Habit number
three is practice mindfulness with Sam
Harris move on from the story or how do
you do it do you live with a lot of
worry each day or are you so good now at
just saying this doesn't matter you know
this is in the past or I'm concerned
about something that's not going to
happen potentially in the future so let
me get back to present like how do you
know that work well so I mean everything
for me sort of at my level of practice
and I've done a lot of meditation
practice but you know there's there's
apparently much more to do in my case
because you still worry yeah well no so
I I I can
I I there's there's no emotion that I
don't experience right so I can I can
experience you know intense anger
intense sadness do depression you worry
all of it
um and the difference for me and this is
something that that you know I wouldn't
have but for the fact that I've really
learned to practice mindfulness the
difference is
when my suffering becomes at all intense
it functions as a kind of mindfulness
alarm right like and so like the the
truly kind of mediocre path for me is to
be within the range of sort of normal
annoyance and normal desire and level
suffering yeah and where the alarm's not
going off and I'm just you know uh kind
of a normal jerk you know within that
within those bounds right like you know
a little anxious here and there yes I
could go to the dry cleaner and and
discover that they you know destroyed my
suit right so I guess I was like this
this in the scheme of things this does
not matter at all right but but you're
frustrated yourself
what do you do you know so it's like
attention is captured and when attention
is captured by that you know I'm the
same guy I always was right right you're
always a jerk yeah well just like
whatever it's like or attention can be
captured pleasantly by something that
you're like oh God this is the best
bagel I've ever had right so I'm like
I'm just going for the food
and there's no perspective you know like
I'm not I'm not you know the
Consciousness is trimmed down to just
the the pleasure or pain of that
experience for that moment right
um and that all of those moments for me
have the character of being
they really are they're deeply analogous
to being asleep and dreaming and not
knowing that you're dreaming right so
the reality is you're in your bed you
know prone or or supine or you know
you're just you're you're in a situation
that's completely
unlike the situation you think you're in
and you think you're on a beach you know
talking to somebody or you know arguing
with somebody who showed up at a
conference and you you know you didn't
have your pants you know whatever
whatever it is and
um you know you're relating to people
who don't exist right and uh I mean just
I mean we're psychotic When We're
Dreaming we're completely confused right
unless it's a lucid dream right which is
its own interesting experience
um but assuming your dreams are not
Lucid you are you are completely
[Music]
unaware of a larger con the true larger
context to your experience and and
you're merely
Hostage to whatever is playing out in
that dream yeah right you know so and
that and that most of experience that is
mediated by thought uh and the you know
look apart from mindfulness most
experience has that character so for me
once you turn up the the dial on intense
the intensity of the experience
then I begin then then something else
comes online for me more reliably
um
and then
you can you know if you really know how
to meditate you can break the spell
decisively in an instant yeah and and in
that instant you are for you you have
woken up I mean you're no longer in bed
uh sleep right and
um so I can do that
um I mean there's sort of too loud I
mean I guess there are two landmarks I
would suggest to notice I mean if
somebody's practicing meditation and
they're and they're
um really get into it I would say that
they're kind of two points that I I
would I would flag as points of real
durable progress the first is
um just to know just to notice the
difference between being lost in thought
and clearly paying attention to
experience you know prior to thought
prior to Concepts
um and so that's that's my that's sort
of the small and mindfulness that that
people learn you know once they start a
practice
um and that has the consequences of if
you do that enough if you keep if you
keep punctuating your ordinary
experience would that just
non-judgmental non-reactive acceptance
of what the present moment is right so
you feel anxiety you feel irritation you
become mindful you just become
interested in that feeling in the in
just the neurophysiology of it the the
the sensation of it you get out of your
thinking about all the reasons why you
should feel anxious or you shouldn't you
should feel irritated you just become
merely present with the experience and
then you notice this kind of Half-Life
it just dissipates right and that's um
there's a certain kind of freedom in
that
there's another point which you know in
my in my meditation app I spent a lot of
time trying to push people toward you
know earlier than is is conventional
there's another point where you can you
realize that the the feeling of self the
feeling that there's a subject in the
center of experience is an illusion
right it's actually not there if you
look you can look for it deliberately
enough that we are an illusion yeah so
it's not that your body is an illusion
it's not that people are Illusions but
the sense that you have that you are a
subject in your head
rocking or riding around in the body
like you're that they're you're behind
your face in this moment like like you
and I are talking I'm looking at you in
the normal the default situation is for
you to feel
implicated by my gaze like I'm I'm look
I'm looking at something like you're on
the other side of my gaze right I mean
my mind is or my my conscience is you
it's like like I like you're you there's
something you know if you say something
and I'm and I've you know get a weird
expression on my face like I don't
believe you or whatever you you can can
read that back into it sort of it it
falls back to you it's like it points
back to you like if I if I Point At You
it feels like I'm pointing at something
I mean this feels rude this feels this
is normally a rude gesture right right
so it's like you feel like like I mean
you're over there you're behind your
face right you know
and that's that's what we call I I mean
that's that's that the personal pronoun
pronoun for most people refers to the
fear that feeling of being in the head
it doesn't refer to the whole body you
know it doesn't refer to
um because people don't feel identical
to their whole bodies they feel like
passengers in their bodies they feel
like subjects they feel like the center
of experience
um
and I mean the real goal of meditation
is to recognize that that is an illusory
position that's actually not your
position there really is just experience
there's there's just Consciousness and
it's contents and there's no Center to
it and
so at a certain point mindfulness can
become the experience of just
cutting through that illusion right so
you're not it's not that you're having
to be strategically mindful of anxiety
or anything else that you may notice
that you you want to have dissipate you
suddenly recognize that there's just no
Center to experience and then then your
meditation practice becomes recognizing
that in each moment and that has the
that has the the consequence of
just I mean that's synonymous with not
being lost in thought in that moment
it's synonymous with not giving any more
energy therefore to this reaction you're
having is synonymous with no resistance
to whatever is appearing right so you so
you're actually free
even before the physiology of the
negative State dissipates also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there habit number four is take care of
your health with Lewis house take care
of your physical health work out eat
clean physical and mental health the
emotional and mental stress can can
really lean into the physical damage if
we don't have a clean healthy
relationship with the mental and
emotional side of ourselves creating
boundaries and all that other stuff but
taking care of your body consistently
moving your body exercising is so
important for your overall physical and
mental health we've had so many
different experts come on and talk about
the research and the science of how
physical movement increases happiness
increases dopamine makes you feel more
confident in all these things being
stagnant for two weeks and not moving
your body will make you feel less and
less confident make you feel weak and
all those different feelings will create
stress anxiety in your life
when you don't exercise you're not
giving your body the clarity it needs
it's not cleansing itself it's not
moving and you've got to move in order
to get you closer towards your desired
goals as well so you got to think about
these things what does your body need
it's it's something that I've started
talking about more and more as I've
started to integrate this more and more
in my life and I started taking boxing
lessons a couple times a week six months
ago and it's transformed my physical and
mental health you might have to reassess
like are the physical activities I'm
doing right now supporting me or do I
need to mix it up do I need to try
something new do I need a new challenge
that's what I did with boxing I've been
able to lift and run and and play sports
my whole life but I felt like I needed
something to shift me physically and
boxing was something I'd never done
something that was challenging it's
mental it's emotional and physical and
it's one of the hardest workouts I've
ever done so I go early in the morning
and I do that because that's been huge
for me because it means I can take care
of the most important and often the
hardest things first which set up the
rest of my day for success and when I
finish a workout early in the morning
and I realized wow there's still a lot
of people that are asleep who haven't
gotten up who haven't done anything and
I'm finishing one of the hardest things
of the day for me that brings me joy
that makes me a better human that makes
me feel more confident makes me feel
happier that that detoxes things that I
need to let go of when I do that I feel
like wow what's next what is there that
I need to do I can do anything bring it
to me I will take on the world today and
when you start the day with that
momentum I really support you with your
overall happiness now if you're not
often Physically Active Don't overwhelm
yourself and say I'm going to do two
hours a day of activity and I'm going to
go crazy here and I'm going to sign up
for all these classes because you'll
burn out quick or you'll hurt yourself
you can start as small as just going for
a 10 20 minute walk around the block
five days a week and really get started
just get yourself moving on the process
of consistency and even if you're making
small progress that progress is
signaling your brain of the changes that
you are wanting to make and again 5 10
20 minutes a day will act eventually be
30 and 60 minutes a day and will
continue to build and compound over time
so don't overwhelm Yourself by thinking
you have to go extremely crazy right off
the bat and I'm going to eat perfect
seven days a week I'm going to train
like a machine and I'm gonna get 12
hours of sleep and all these things
you're probably not gonna be able to
sustain that within two weeks but
getting started and being consistent is
the key so anything is better than
nothing when it comes to moving your
body and the next thing is really to
focus on your diet I know when I'm not
eating clean consistently I kind of take
the 80 20 approach for for nutrition and
food 80 of the time I try to eat as
clean and healthy and organic as
possible 20 of the time I'm traveling
the weekends I I have more sugar and
desserts and things that I know aren't
the best for the fuel for my body but
they they taste good and I give myself
that balance and you can work out all
you want but you can't outwork your
mouth that's for sure you cannot out
work your mouth
you can train for an hour and then if
you're having all this cakes and cookies
it's not going to do anything for you
you're actually not doing any favors for
yourself you might be maintaining but
you're not really improving and our
guests all the time talk about eating
things like I've had so many different
scientists doctors and nutritionists
about the top foods you should be eating
and they all consistently say
blueberries foods that are high in
omega-3 fatty acids like salmon and
walnuts and avocado oil dark chocolate
the list goes on and on from there leafy
greens all that stuff but eating more of
those things adding more of those things
into your your your body will support
you and you don't want to put in so much
effort on your workout routine and then
just go have you know alcohol and sugar
and pizza every night that's not going
to really support you grow you can have
cheat meals in moderation or you can
just call it balanced meals in
moderation if you don't want to call it
cheat meals I do the balanced 80 20 kind
of percent Rule and having a Clean Diet
will not but having a Clean Diet will
not only serve you physically and your
health but also in your mental health
because we've talked about so many
different experts that have come on and
share that the foods that actually
increase your mental health and affect
your mood we've had a lot of these
different doctors and nutritionists come
on and talk about that and when you're
eating poorly it can increase the
feelings of depression anxiety and
stress and I believe we're starting to
really understand more about how much
our diet really affects us how much food
really can either hurt us or heal us so
for your future self it's best if you
focus not only on putting your bodies
through the workouts but also giving
your body the cleanest Foods possible to
eat habit number five is write down your
power phrases with Dean graziosi success
starts at your core success starts with
the right habits with the right
principles with the right values
everybody's trying to plug in the get
rich quick schemes on top of the wrong
foundation on top of the wrong rules and
you wonder why you go from opportunity
to opportunity and you never go deep you
never make the money you never become a
millionaire because never become
financially independent I will scream
from the mountaintops maybe it's my age
maybe it's the success I've I've been
blessed to have but I obsess on looking
backwards understanding what got me here
it wasn't cars when I was in high school
it wasn't cutting firewood when I was in
early High School it wasn't real estate
it wasn't uh building houses or renting
houses or flipping houses yes that was
the end result writing books creating
courses doing Live Events yes that was
the end result to massive success in my
life blessed beyond belief but if I go
Upstream if I really look at what got me
here what powered through unsupportive
parents or friends or not having money
and not having a college education not
feeling that smart not having the
confidence in some cases had nothing to
do with those
it had to do with the principles that
we're talking about right here on the
millionaire success habits podcast
that's why I always say all success
starts here well today there's a there's
a yellow a white pad that I wanted to
share with you and today I want to talk
about the power of projection the power
of writing down an incantation as Tony
Robbins likes to talk about writing down
a phrase your power phrase something you
can say but it hasn't happened yet I
know that sounds weird right I'm sure
you've maybe heard of the secret and
manifestation I get all that but that's
kind of not the rules that I follow I
know that there has to be action taken
in order to get to the end result you
want you could say I'm a millionaire I'm
a millionaire I'm a millionaire I have
freedom I have joy but if you don't get
your ass off the couch if you don't take
action if you don't put the the the the
the thoughts in your mind into play that
it's something you're just going to be
talking about for the rest of your life
so I love the fact of projecting I love
the fact of pretending it's a year from
now and thinking through what the best
year of your life is like and feeling it
let those emotions hit but then you got
to go out there and take action so I
wanted to share with you really raw uh
what's on this page
uh this page in front of me if you're
watching video you'd see it but I'll
just talk about it because I've only
held it up for a second anyway
um
in 2017 2016 2017 I went through a
divorce didn't tell anybody didn't tell
the world it was so frightening to me I
can't even tell you it was frightening
to me because I love being a dad I love
seeing my kids every single day I knew
the relationship wasn't wasn't right we
both knew for a very long time but we
were both petrified well when the
divorce was actually happening and I
actually moved out of the house I I got
anxiety I got fears I got worries things
from my childhood my parents were
married nine times when I was young and
that that obviously left an impression
left something that I bottled up like
picture a champagne bottle that I tucked
in all the fears all the worries all the
loneliness missing my mom when she moved
away all those things I tucked them down
into this champagne bottle and I put a
tight damn lid on it and I found a way
to thrive through business through life
through obsessing on personal growth
obsessing on success getting good
friendships and relationships to my life
and I ignored that part for a gazillion
years and then all of a sudden when I
faced divorce I faced leaving my kids
and waking up in a house and they're not
there it was like the top of the
champagne bottle
popped off and it all came flooding out
like oh my God in my head I'm like I
work on this every day I write books on
it this is who I am and then I go visit
my friends
people that I'm blessed to to believe it
they're the greatest in the planet when
it comes to taking your life to another
level and they expressed that they went
through similar things and we all had to
face it so with that said I did a lot of
things to try to get through this I
focused I couldn't think through it even
though I thought I could I couldn't
think through a better future so I
started writing down you could call them
incantations you could start you could
call them whatever you want future
pacing you could call them empowerment
phrases but I want to share with you
what I wrote down in 2017. I feel love
when I give love
think about that instead of feeling love
when someone gives it to you
I want to feel loved one I give it look
how look at that is that's just the
reframing of love so many of us go
through life and what's this got to do
with success everything because if your
internal is off your external can't work
right so for me I said if I Feel Love
it's going to be because I give love not
because I need it because I would feel
like I'm going to be missing my kids I'm
not going to be in a relationship or
whatever that is right I never here's
I'm never alone this is my personal
beliefs I'm never alone because God is
always with me then I my next thing I
said all I need to be successful I
already have I just have to turn inward
I wrote down I can get through this and
will be a better father a better man a
better leader a better teacher and I'll
do the world a Justice if I get through
this
my next level is the next one my next
level of life is on the other side of
this biggest fear face it
fear is gone once you face it
authenticity is the key to happiness
think about that authenticity is the key
to happiness yes blatant obsessive
authenticity what's on your mind what's
on your heart the [ __ ] has to stop
the cover-up has to stop I knew that
authenticity was the key to my happiness
I let myself love with no fear love with
resistance love with worry could go away
love with being upset it's not real love
it's restricted Love Again going back to
the first one I'm gonna feel loved when
I give love not when I receive it so I
might as well give the most love I
possibly have to give the next one I
wrote down is I won't manage my emotions
I will let them be raw I'll feel them
and I'll work through them think about
that let your emotions be raw who wants
that right you want to tuck it back in
that champagne bottle no I saw what
happened when the court came off leave
the bottle off let emotions come feel it
process it and let them flow right
through you now there's a lot more
there's four pages here but I'm only
going to give you one more Direction
determines my destination
when insecure tell the truth now why did
I read you this so personal this was me
I've gotten through the biggest business
deals you could ever imagine from that
kid cutting firewood and and you know
flipping uh cars I've gone on to you
know do incredible things and live a
life I could have only dreamed of
but I don't know if I dealt with it on
the depths in my personal life when I
look back at this and I wrote this in
2017 guess what I didn't focus on this
every day
I didn't I I didn't uh directly create
the path and plan on how to get these
but I took action immediately I remember
saying these for almost a month straight
every day and it was almost like the
universe God took over and started
guiding me in those directions remember
I didn't just sit and say when I give
love I'll feel up when I give love I'll
feel it I said it but I was consciously
aware that when I gave extra love to the
people that work on me extra loved in my
family extra love to my kids I said wow
and I remember feeling Goosebumps so I
was living I was taking action with it I
wasn't just talking about it I want to
tell you now almost a year and a half
later from writing this down I do feel
love when I give love
I never feel alone when I used to I
think because my parents were married
and divorced I was alone a lot I think
inside I felt a fear of going to be
abandoned just being honest this is
transparent and raw as I can get I don't
it's gone I uh all I need is with inside
me I know that I create my authenticity
I can create my enthusiasm I create my
happiness the world's not responsible
for my happiness my spouse or future
spouse or kids they're not responsible
for my happiness I am and I can create
it
my next level of Life did live on the
other side of my biggest fear turn your
ship towards the thing you've been
avoiding and face it and deal with it go
through the storm on the other side of
the storm is the next level of calm
Happiness joy abundance fear is gone
when you face it authenticity I've been
more authentic in my life than ever
before I don't have one single secret
nothing and it feels so incredibly
congruent to who I am as a man how would
that feel well there's nothing people
just know you you're not somebody
different for a million different people
and if you could see why this is so
important to your next level of success
whatever that success means to in your
life habit number six is use the power
of self-talk with Marie forleo if you've
got some bad habits that just keep
derailing your success and you are ready
to break them for good this episode my
friend is a must watch now here's why
we're talking about this a few weeks ago
during a company meeting someone asked
for some ideas to break a late night
cookies and ice cream have it this
person said and I quote it's like I turn
into a child at 9 00 pm and I have to
have my cookies and my ice cream before
bed this needs to stop and I mean I
could relate I don't think that there is
any human on the planet who at any given
time doesn't have at least one habit
that really needs to get kicked to the
curb well it turns out that there's a
simple two-word fix that can
dramatically increase our ability to
resist temptation and it gives us a
better chance to make a better choice
now this is based on Research done by Dr
Vanessa Patrick she's a professor of
marketing at the University of Houston
who published her findings on the power
of self-talk in the Journal of consumer
research she found that when
participants framed a refusal as I don't
for instance I don't eat chocolate cake
or I don't eat sugar instead of I can't
they were more successful at resisting
the desire to eat unhealthy Foods or
skip the gym in fact they found that
when it came to deciding whether to eat
certain foods saying I don't was nearly
three times as effective as saying no
and about eight times more effective
than saying I can't
very interesting right I don't versus I
can't two teeny tiny words that can make
a ginormous difference and here's why
when we say I don't we are empowered
we're determined we are at Choice it's a
tough strong phrase like end of story
but when we say I can't we disempower
ourselves it sounds like we're not
allowed to do something by some outside
force you know what we make ourselves
feel deprived when we say I can and in
essence we make ourselves weak whiny
little [ __ ] like when I can't have a
cookie now it's even cooler though is
that we can tuck this little trick into
every corner of our Lives we can start
making some clear strong declarations
like this
I don't eat skinny pop every night
I don't look at my phone during dinner
I don't unnecessarily use the marietv
set
I don't put the toilet seat down
I don't refer to everyone whose name I
don't immediately remember as
chimichanga
I don't show up to the set of marietv
nude
starting tomorrow
[Music]
I don't stay up until 3am watching bear
attack videos rubbing Fried Chicken all
over my thighs
I don't say no to new experiences
I don't shave
pretty awesome right and if you ever
forget about this little two-word
miracle I want you to power up this
tweetable
when you need the strength to resist a
bad habit I don't is stronger than I
can't inhabit number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
replace negative thoughts with Brian
Tracy what happened the last time you
made a mistake were you able to step
back and see what went wrong and fix it
or were you so hard on yourself that you
couldn't see past what happened
too often we allow negative self-talk to
stop us in our tracks instead of using
mistakes as a motivator to propel us
forward
here are some tips where you can use
failure to help Propel you forward to
greater success
first make sure that you're talking
positively to yourself we are constantly
giving ourselves internal messages that
can either Inspire or reprimand the
trouble is that most people tend to be
too harsh on themselves and the more you
talk negatively to yourself or the more
you rehash a negative event the less
motivated you will feel this can
actually set you up for failure in the
future
psychologists know the importance of the
internal Loop this is a program set of
thoughts that we say to ourselves over
and over again if those thoughts are
negative they will affect the way that
you see yourself and this can keep you
from taking the kind of risks needed to
succeed the next time you catch yourself
saying something a negative to yourself
internally stop and listen really listen
are you berating your decisions and
actions or are you giving yourself the
kind of Silent pep talk that you need to
move forward
it's important to recognize the kind of
messages that you send yourself all day
every day you may be surprised at how
harmful many of these messages really
are
negative self-talk is like a disease it
grabs a hold of you and doesn't want to
let go
so don't let negative thoughts ruin your
success turn those negative messages
into positive ones sound impossible it
isn't but it does take some practice
here are a few tips to help you quiet
the inner critic inside of you
it's important that you acknowledge what
you're really saying to yourself we do
it all the time without ever realizing
the damage it can cause take some time
today to take note of the messages that
you are sending internally listen to how
you talk to yourself
once you begin to recognize the message
is it you could be hurting your ability
to perform you'll be in a better
position to challenge those thoughts the
next time they come up
now that you recognize the rotten
messages you are feeding yourself it's
time to make some changes remember you
are stuck with those unhealthy messages
every negative thought you create can be
transformed into a positive thought
take the time to turn negative thoughts
into more positive and constructive ones
while it's okay to acknowledge where
improvements can be made in your life
constantly dwelling on what they are is
going to sap you of energy and
motivation
to help break the loop of negativity
Begin by making a list of all the things
that you are good at and keep it where
you can see it on a regular basis add a
new items regularly this is a good
reminder of the improvements that you
have made along the way already but it's
not all you also have to review that
list when you are feeling down for any
reason it's a great way to give yourself
a quick pick me up
once you begin to concentrate on the
good things going for you the more
negative aspects will begin to lose
their power and eventually fall away
here's the rule never say anything to
yourself about yourself that you do not
want to be true practice this with the
members of your family if you do not
want it to be a true statement about
them don't say it and it won't become a
true statement every time you notice
yourself ascending an internal message
that is less than positive take a moment
to change it to something positive
stop being so hard on yourself
readjusting your attitude and changing
your sour thoughts into productive ones
is going to take a bit of work and
concentration but it's essential to you
becoming the kind of person that gets
things done
before we wrap up I'd like to leave you
with a thought to share with your
friends and followers say the words I
like myself over and over 50 times a day
I like myself I like myself I like
myself
now I'd love to hear from you so my
question today is this have you ever
caught yourself Talking negatively to
yourself about yourself
what did you do to snap out of it
leave a comment below and I'll be sure
to follow up with you
thanks for watching and remember if you
want to change your future take action
and take action now
collect good people
get into the habit of collecting good
people
I think when you're finding friends it's
especially hard as an adult you know
when you're in school when your kid
even even at University if you're part
of clubs or groups or houses it's easier
to form friendships because you're
you're collaborating you're there you're
you're forced to be in class with people
and you're going to say hi and get to
know them but we don't really have that
as adults you know and I think we find
our friend Circle shrinking and
shrinking and shrinking as we get older
and you end up having
some work friends maybe but you don't
get into a lot of specifics often
because there's Dynamics in politics
and then you kind of try to maintain
your friends from high school or college
but it's hard because everybody's gone
off and done different things and often
you've outgrown them you know you've
grown in different ways and we stain
friendships out of convenience
I'm introverted I'm shy
that doesn't always come across in
videos you know I put my let's go spread
the mission and the message had on when
I'm making content but I don't talk to
people on the airplane I don't say hi I
don't introduce myself very awkward I
hate small talk and so that can make it
difficult to to form friends
what I found
as my rallying cry is I want to collect
good people
and when I find somebody that I like for
whatever reason you know like your your
heart will guide you on these things
there's people that you've been around
that you just like
you know if you met somebody you just
want to spend more time with
and and maybe you met them at an event
maybe you maybe they're a friend of a
friend maybe maybe you just met them
online somewhere
but you just you like them and you want
to spend more time with them
get into the habit of collecting good
people so this is a two-step process
that I think will be valuable for you
step one is to put yourself in the new
situations step one is to be around the
people the groups the clubs the
activities where like-minded people are
doing things
I just launched my Discord server you
can join us Evan carmichael.biz it's
super fun I'm in there every day
chatting with people and the people who
have joined are entrepreneurs who want
to build their business you know they
want to build their life they they don't
know a lot of people don't know whether
entrepreneur is it you know you are the
most optimistic person you're the one
pouring into other people so who do you
hang out with who pours into you well
too often it's nobody so come join our
Discord but if not that then go go put
yourself in the situations where you
have the chance to meet new people like
if you just stay at home running your
business and you just repeat the same
routine that you've got and you're never
exposing yourself to people then you're
never going to meet new people you know
if you're not going to events or
conferences or clubs or rooms you're not
going to meet people and I know that's
scary and that's difficult that's hard
that that is
even as I say those words the introvert
and shy person in me is already tense
enough like oh but I hate it so much I
hate networking I hate these events I I
don't want to go I just want to stay
home and do my thing I'm not going to
meet anybody it's going to be terrifying
I'm going to stand in the back of the
room and not talk to anybody
so that's why it's important to pick
groups that you actually resonate with
there's very few things that will get me
going and get me excited I hate small
talk I don't want to talk about the
weather and how it's raining here in
Toronto today I don't want to talk about
politics or climate or news cycle stuff
the things most people talk about I
don't care I don't want to talk about
gossip and other people zero interest to
me
in a lot of networking events that's
that's you know you're covering really
basic things it seemed very
uninteresting to me but if you put me in
a room of entrepreneurs
or you put me in a room of salsa dancers
but you put me in a room of people who
like League of Legends and Minecraft
I would find something to talk about
it'd be a lot more easy for me to start
a conversation
and so that's what I encourage you to do
around your interest around your passion
around the thing that you are generally
curious about learning as well as
helping other people with then join
those groups because there's lots of
those kinds of groups out there it may
be in your city or online for sure
online for sure there are groups again
join us Evan carmichael.biz on Discord
come say hi looking forward to meeting
you by putting yourself so Step One is
putting yourself in those rooms so that
you are you're you have the ability to
reach new people and then step two is
when you find somebody that you like
you be the initiator to try to find a
way to spend more time together
you know if you find somebody at event
or if you see somebody in the message
board or you're joining the Discord and
you love somebody's perspective
say hey I'd love to learn more about you
and what you're doing you want to do a
zoom call together or do you want to
they're in your city do you want to go
grab some coffee together
and lean it's hard this is hard again
the introvert I mean is like oh my God
my heart's beating this is crazy for the
extroverts out there you're like this is
easy what's the problem heroin
but for the introverts like oh my God
this is the scariest thing of all time
boom boom boom boom boom boom
lean into the awkwardness and and say I
love your Vibe I'd love to learn more
about you and how you do X
do you have time this weekend to grab a
coffee
or if they hop on a zoom
and that could be again around
entrepreneurship for me be
entrepreneurship I'd love to learn more
about your business
do you have time this weekend for a
quick Zoom or if it was Minecraft I
could say I love how you do all of your
Redstone I love to know how you do it do
you you want to hop on a quick Zoom call
right like people are often flattered
and chances are here's what happens guys
if you had a good vibe about them
they probably have a good vibe about you
right like if you have a good vibe about
them they probably have a good vibe
about you probably right
but they're too afraid to do anything
about it either
this is why you have to lean into the
awkwardness
and so I've done this
over and over and over and over again
and it's led to some just amazing people
being around me but it took me a long
time to do it you know it took me too
long to get started I wish I'd learned
this when I was first getting started as
an entrepreneur because I was so
isolated and so alone and didn't know
who to talk to and just
me and my business partners and my
family that's that's it you know I had
no other circle of people to connect
with
I think of someone like Jeremy who I've
mentored in his business
she really liked them there's something
about him I really liked them when I
first met him he came to my event
I was doing my thought Leadership
Academy in Toronto it was a three-day
event that he came out to and he was the
youngest one there he was he was still
in his teens late teens that he came out
and uh
spent all the money he had almost to be
there he was a it was a couple thousand
bucks to be there and he was earning
minimum wage as a grocery store clerk at
a store here in Toronto
and there's something about them I
really like this guy he was super green
just started getting into personal
development learned about it through
watching one of my videos and
I had a really soft spot in my heart for
Him I really liked him
and after the event was over he he
didn't want it to be over he's like yeah
I learned so much from this I don't want
to go back to you know the life that I
had Evan how can I how can I spend more
time with you I'll cut your grass I'll
mow your mow your Lawns the same thing
I'll walk your dogs I'll wash your car
you know I'll do your groceries like
what do you need me to do I just wanna I
don't want it to end I want to spend
more time
and I didn't have an idea for him you
know it's like I don't need somebody to
walk my dog you know just Anna's she's
good I don't need somebody to mobile I
don't have a lawn I'm in a condo
the car's getting washed out here in the
rain anyway
and so I didn't I didn't have anything
for him but then
it's just stuck with me you know it just
stuck with me
I really like this guy
I want to collect good people and I
don't know what I'm going to do with him
but I from for a couple months it just
stuck with me and then the idea came to
me I want to start a business with him
I'm going to teach him how to do YouTube
and we're going to set up a YouTube
Consulting business for him so he can
leave his job and he can do what he
what he loves doing and keep learning
and growing and be around the energy
and he said yes we got him out of call
he said yes fast forward now you know he
he
had this momentous day where he was
making more in one month than he did in
an entire year and he went and burned
his uh apron that he had to wear at the
grocery store it was a big momentum day
for him and that was you know mid six
figure business
which is fantastic but more than just
helping this guy build a business it's
just I love the energy and I love
spending time with him and I love
collecting good people
so
when you're around people who fill you
up
when you're around people who believe in
you when you're on people who give you
energy you're probably the one giving
other people energy filling them up
right and it's fantastic keep doing that
because you're built to serve and you
should keep doing that but when you're
around those people
just makes you feel better
it's so hard just to keep going when
everyone around you is negative or toxic
or just tearing you down or in a lot of
pain themselves and telling you that
your ideas won't work
and they hate their life you know it's
it's really hard to keep going living
your dreams when everyone around you
hates their life
and you know how good it feels to be
around people who are doing their thing
who fill you up
and so you have to start to collect with
people
you have to start to put yourself in
situations where you have the chance to
meet good people around the things that
you care about
and then you have to have the courage to
ask somebody to go to a coffee
or to hop on a zoom call
because if you fast forward and imagine
the next year of your life
imagine that your option A surrounded by
people who are negative and are hating
their life and in a lot of pain all the
time or matching you being surrounded by
people who are
filling you up encouraging you
supporting you lifting you up giving you
positive messages cheering you on
imagine a year of that how much more do
you accomplish how much further do you
go
how much more could you serve
how close would you be to your goals
because you chose to surround yourself
with people you chose to be courageous
it's not easy for the introverts out
there it's not easy
but you chose to be courageous
and you chose to collect good people
[Music]
because you made it this far new video I
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know the simple routines that
generate massive wealth check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there you know like when you're
driving and the cop lights go on and
that your heart goes but then when the
cop Drives By you're like you feel real
good and then you start driving with two
hands and the speed limit for about four
minutes and then you go back to being
like ridiculous